la campagne municipale et élancé à
mantes la ville comme une importante
pour le rassemblement national le parti
à la tête de la municipalité avec son
maire cyril note face à cette majorité
un collectif citoyen baptisé nous
mentent villois s'est constitué avec une
sensibilité de gauche
depuis 2014 et jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a
fait le constat douloureux d'une gestion
municipale de mantes-la-ville
catastrophique sur tous les sujets
toutes les prérogatives de la ville par
sa majorité actuelle front national et
face à ce constat là et face à cette
urgence et face aux autres urgences qui
sont des urgences environnementales les
urgences sociales et l'urgence
démocratique
on a décidé nous habitants de mantes la
ville de prendre les devants et avec nos
voisins avec les habitants de la ville
de construire la ville de demain et pour
construire leur projet municipal
l'association souhaite faire participer
les citoyens pendant ces douze mois
utilisée chaque seconde pour solliciter
et faire participer la plus nos voisins
pour pour construire à la fois les
priorités et par rapport à ses priorités
la dégager les solutions qui sont
adaptées au contexte de mantes la ville
parallèlement à cela un front
républicain pourrait voir le jour à
travers une union entre les républicains
et le parti socialiste
quant à cyril note il n'a pas encore
officialisé sa candidature